قال منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي قال ان
واشنطن لن تتردد في توجيه ضربات اخرى
للحوثيين اذا استمروا في شن هجماتهم على
الملاحه الدوليه واضاف كيربي ان التصنيف
جماعه انصر الله منظمه ارهابيه لا يستهدف
الشعب
اليمني تصنيفنا اليوم للحوثيين منظمه
ارهابيه لا يستهدف الشعب اليمني نعتقد ان
15 مليون شخص في اليمن ما يزالون بحاجه
الى الماء والغذاء والدواء واتخذنا
اجراءات من اجل استمرار توفير هذا الدعم
لهم هذا التصنيف سيدخل حيز التنفيذ بعد
شهر من اليوم اذا توقف الحوثيون عن هذه
الهجمات
فسنجان منظمه ارهابيه وان لم يتراجعوا كما
قال الرئيس فلن نتردد في توجيه ضربات اخرى
لحمايه شعبنا وسلامه التجاره العالميه
yeah